17 minutes avant son lancement officiel
la nouvelle tombe la nasa et space x
décide d'annuler le décollage de crewe
dragonne en raison des conditions
météorologiques
prochaine date de lancement prévue donc
ce soir la nouvelle ère du transport
spatial aura bien lieu à l'initiative de
l'entrepreneur milliardaire hillen musk
space x est la première société privée à
envoyer des astronautes dans l'espace
de quoi rendre aux américains leur
autonomie de l'accès à l'espace c'est la
première fois depuis neuf ans que les
états unis lanceront une fusée de
conception américaine sans dépendre des
russes depuis 2011 et le dernier vol de
la navette spatiale atlantis aucune
fusée américaine n'a envoyé d'humain
dans l'espace une page de l'histoire se
tourne donc et une du transport spatial
s'ouvre cette capsule va notamment
permettre l'ouverture de nouveaux
marchés de services de transport
spatiaux un enjeu primordial pour il
admet sq qui depuis dix-huit ans
travaille à faire de space x un acteur
spatiale majeur mais un enjeu également
pour donald trump qui avait fait de
l'indépendance spatiale une promesse de
campagne
un succès stratégique attendus pour le
président américain